okay so we're going to talk about this
wonderful instrument called the vuvuzela
which has been i guess criticized very
heavily in very many places you know
because it features throughout all the
world cup games people are blowing it
incessantly
you can hear it very clearly on on
different
world cup commentaries
i'll try i'm not the best at this but
i'll try and get a tone out of it
like any other wind instrument that you
actually think that you blow into the
way it works is that you set up a
resonance of air inside the column and
it's that resonance of air that that
gives the air moving back and forth
rapidly inside the column at a
particular frequency which is set by the
the the length of the column microphone
laptop the microphone is being fed into
a usb port here okay so what what we're
going to do now is we're going to take
one phrase this is philip moriarty
university of nottingham for 60 symbols
this is philip moriarty university of
nottingham for 60 symbols right so let's
save that so here's phil who's a keen
amateur trombonist self-described and
what he's going to do is play a note on
the versailles much better than i can
three two one
what we're going to do here is load in
that sample of my speech and we're going
to look at the
frequency spectrum university of
nottingham for 60 symbols so what we
have here is a frequency spectrum of
that free as i said and you can see that
there are lots and lots of different
peaks spread across this is going from
100 hertz up to about 3 kilohertz and
those are the the primary components of
maybe the primary frequencies in my
voice we look at the reverse zela
so if we look at this frequency spectrum
you see that it actually differs quite
substantially from the spectrum of my
voice and what we see here we've got
three very well defined peaks in this
spectrum this one here we call the
fundamental that's the lowest wavelength
the lowest frequency that can exist in
that tube and that's about 220 hertz now
i know from the physics of that
instrument that this without even
measuring it that this would be 440
twice times 220
and this would be six round about 663
times 220. so that's the fundamental
what we call the second harmonic and the
third harmonic now so what we're going
to do now is while phil plays that note
i'm going to try and say the exact same
phrase i said before
these are very loud instruments so i
might have to shout quite a bit and then
we're going to see if we can
filter out the sound of the vivazula
from the sound of my voice right okay
three two one
so that's that's the problem
the the commentators have um with the
matches in that you've got this
incredible drone going on all the time
in the background and you're trying to
hear you're you're trying to make
yourself heard above that drone and so
that's why the television companies are
very very interested in trying to filter
out that drone from the sound of the
voice and now what i'll do is i'll try
and take you through just how we do that
or just how the companies do it
so let's load in
that
speech and vuva zela sample again
and let's play that back row
what i'm going to do now is i'm going to
filter out
these first three harmonics so the one
roughly 220 440 and 660. and let's hear
what difference that makes to the the
sound
so this is philip moriarty university of
nottingham for 60 symbols
so you can hear immediately that the
sound of my voice with respect to the
sound of the vivezella has come up um
it's clearer you can get a bit more
definition but you can still hear the
vuvuzela and the reason you can hear the
vuvuzela as you well you can see almost
from here you can see that as well as
these three very strong harmonics we
have these other harmonics and in fact
if i blew up the scale here you'd see
that the harmonics going all the way out
here so let's try it again
but this time instead of doing just
those three harmonics let's do eight
harmonics and see what difference that
makes so this is phil moriarty
university of nottingham for 60 symbols
so you can still hear it in the
background and if i continue this
process we could get rid of more and
more of that river zela but the problem
is while we're getting rid of the
viewers zela we're also taking out bits
of the frequency spectrum associated
with myspace so you've got to draw this
balance this compromise and that's why
it's
impossible to totally decouple those two
what i've shown you is something called
notch filtering and the reason it's
called notch filtering is that we're
taking little notches out of the
frequency spectrum and getting rid of
those that's that's straightforward
that's very simple to do now there's a
rather less reputable company has
decided that what they're going to do is
they're going to supply a recording an
mp3 of the vuvuzula sound that they
argue has been recorded so it's in
anti-phase and antiphase means that the
peaks and the troughs of the waves line
up so the idea is that you'll cancel out
those waves this is just complete and
utter nonsense if you see this on the
web and you see some sort of recording
or mp3 that you can download for three
dollars or ten dollars or three pound or
299 or whatever just don't buy it